hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game between aron grigori which
rescue and oleg kaminsky was played in
1972 leningrad
championship so uh the same year that
fisher was battling spassky for a world
championship championship title but
this game uh features uh a brilliant
move that
uh well uh obviously is featured in the
thumbnail
uh but we are going to show the entire
game as well as it as it is interesting
i thought about
just showing the final position but
we're gonna go through the game
uh so like i said uh 1972 and i couldn't
find a photo of either of the two
gentlemen so again
uh we have to wear the hoodie while uh
watching this game uh kaminsky was a
feeding master
and uh rescue was uh in 1945 i found an
information that he was joint champion
of the ussr juniors with petrossian and
vasilchuk
so without further ado uh let's check it
out now resco opens with c4
the english opening is on the board
sorry about that
uh we have knight to c knight to f6 uh
the english and uh
now knight to c3 with e5 uh the
the two nice variation of the english
knight f3 and knight to c6 so the four
knights of the english with g3 preparing
to fianchetto the light square bishop
here
and black strikes in the center with the
d5 as you always
should uh we have captures captures and
now bishop to g2 so this is
fairly standard stuff that's played even
today
knight to b6 avoiding any trades on d5
and now
white castles with bishop to e7 black
also prepares the castle
and now a4 white grabbed some space here
on the queen side maybe with ideas of
dislodging the knight with a5 so black
prevents it
a5 himself and b3 now preparing to
fianchetto the
the other uh bishop as well and then you
will have a very nice control of the
board
uh we have castles by black and bishop
to b2 so both players just nicely
developing
we have bishop to e6 by black and it is
as of move 10 that this position has
never been reached again
uh we have knight to b5 and now comes uh
bishop to f6 knight to b5 uh a5 has
already been played so
knight will be very safe here uh black
will have some issues uh
getting it away from there you first
have to move this knight then play c6
but white wants to play rook c1 and then
put some pressure on the c7 pawn
so here bishop to f6 by black also uh
having nice defense of the e5 pawn and
rook the c1 now
uh and here queen to c8 probably with
idea of something like bishop to h3
uh trading off white's uh light square
bishop which is a very important
defender
so here we have d4 by white and now as
the queen moved from the d8 square rook
to d8 now white will not be able to
capture as the queen would hang on d1
so here white goes e4 at some point
preparing uh to push this pawn all the
way to d5
uh not not a great threat as the queen
is still on d1 so
you'll not be able to capture here but
black decides to capture
uh nonetheless so e captures on d5 and
now
you cannot recapture just yet because
the pawn is sufficiently defended so e5
first bishop to e7 and only now knight
f captures on d4 we have knight capture
sunday for
uh bishop captures on d4 and now as the
c7 pawn is being threatened
finally c6 but white doesn't care
even though your knight is under attack
if you move the knight and then this
bishop
becomes a bit shaky you really don't
care because the queen is now on c8 and
black will not be able to capture so
queen e2 getting the queen out of harm's
way and now
knight to d5 uh we have bishop back to
b2
now uh you want to move this knight and
knights to c7 now hoping to get some
trades in but
only now white moves the night knight to
the fourth thing uh you're
you're going to have to try a little bit
harder to uh trade off the pieces so
here
bishop to d5 by black and white grabs
more space here with f4
hoping for some f5 e6 action in the
future
we have capture sun g2 king captures and
now bishop to b4
and here white has to decide how to
proceed there are
a couple of very nice ideas like you
could get the rooks to the d
file try to play it like that but white
goes for the very straightforward
f5 and now f6 might be an idea e6 might
be an idea all depends on what
black plays but black says now you've
got nothing here and play
c5 and here he wants white to move the
knight he wants white to move the knight
for example if knight
to f3 then you can capture on f5 but
white says i don't care about the knight
and plays
e6 and now uh black says
okay this uh this is a fine piece
sacrifice but i i don't think it
actually works and he decides to capture
the knight on d4
so c captures on d5 and now although uh
captures an f7 looks
very strong uh the reality is you can
just capture with the king and now for
example queen c4 check 95
and you don't have an attack uh you you
can either trade pieces here or just
move the queen and then black
also does whatever black wants but it's
not very
not very you know nothing is happening
here
so instead after a c captures on d4
white doesn't capture on f7 but rather
queen to e5
and now maybe if uh you you get rid of
this pawn then maybe you could have some
queen bishop action going towards the g7
uh
pawn going for checkmate so black of
course decides to immediately
uh eliminate this threat so bishop the
c3
and uh here ereshko captures uh with the
bishop
it seems interesting capturing with the
rook kind of
going for a checkmate here but this is
one of those games where f6 is just
uh you know completely winning and white
can
uh just move the queen and then suffer
in in a much worse
game so here uh after bishop c3 we have
bishop captures
uh and now not recapturing right away
because then
well after rook captures you would have
some problems here uh
it's uh impossible to defend this knight
here so instead after bishop captures on
c3 first a nice fission two
we have f6 here pushing back the queen
and now after queen e2
only now d captures on c3 white of
course recaptures and now
uh you don't want to uh just wait for
white to play rook to c1
because then you really lose a piece so
here rook to d6 now preparing to meet
uh rook rook to c1 with ideas like rook
to c6
uh just saving your knight so here white
again goes for the tricky
rook to d1 and black says okay
not a problem rook to c6 so again uh
just uh
not allowing any pressure to be put on
the c file
with rook c to d3 with this little
maneuver white to control of the d
file and now knight to e8 because ideas
like
for example pawn here rook here are
coming so knight the e8 will prevent uh
any rook to d8 uh uh
jumps to to come with check uh and here
we have queen to h5 e7
now doesn't really pose any threats so
yeah it's kind of pointless but queen
the h5 on the other hand it does because
this threatens queen to f7 check king h8
and queen to f8 to checkmate uh we can
even show it for example if white
black plays something weird uh just
queen f7 check and this is now checkmate
so uh instead after this queen to h5
move black decided to play
uh rook to c7 guarding the f7 square
but now comes uh uh now comes uh
uh rook to d7 and here okay white is
again threatening queen f7 check
followed by queen f8 checkmate
so black has to capture and uh instead
of this rook the c7 move black could
have gone for rook to c to check and
then
hopefully trade off at least one pair of
rooks and then take care of the f7
square
but okay like we said rook to c7 was
played rook to d7
and here black decides to give back the
piece and draw
the game so captures captures uh the
queen and the knight are now under
attack
queen to d8 and now uh is the important
part of the game
white can just capture here with check
and trade off everything and go into an
end game where white is better let's say
after rook d5 go after the a5 pawn
uh he's a bit more active but it's hard
to say if it will be enough to win the
game
uh but white is not satisfied with a
draw and he doesn't want to play this
uh captures or or captures which is
obviously the strongest idea
so instead white plays queen to f3 he
allows black to save the knight and he
goes
after the pawn here so knight to c7
black decides to save the piece and now
queen captures on b7 so white says
i'm down a piece for the entire game i
can keep being down a piece as i still
have my past
deep on so king of fade by black and now
rook to c1 going after the knight and
now you don't have a way of
dealing with this you have to capture
the pass pawn and allowable whites to
recapture the piece
so captures we have rook captures on c7
and now queen to d2 check and now we
have this position
where uh it's pretty much impossible for
the white king to
get out of any checks and you don't want
to allow uh the white pieces to start
giving checks along the seventh rank
so here king f3 and we have now a series
of checks queen d1
king f4 queen to d4 check uh seems to be
seems to be a perpetual
and not a lot you can do but queen to e4
now you have to be careful if you just
move the queen then the rook hangs with
check so here queen to d6 check king to
g4
and now not allowing the trade rook to
e8 pushing back the queen
we have queen to c4 now defending the
rook and also threatening checkmate on
f7
so of course rook to e4 with check now
you have to capture and then it's just a
rook trade so captures captures
and now comes a move the only move that
uh
allows white to play for a win b4 uh and
okay now if you allow b5 then you just
to give white a pass pawn and it's going
to be
really hard to stop it so uh captures
and captures with
check and now we have a position three
pawns each on the king's side
we can even use a different color here
but white has a one pass pawn on the
queen side which is incredibly strong
so king to g8 and then now comes a5
white starts pushing his past pawn
with h6 and now a6 by white
king to h7 you want to get out of any
any possible checks in the future and
now
queen to d4 guarding the a7 square you
want to push the pawn
queen to a5 and now a7 and here it's a
question
how does white promote here because uh
it's very easy for this queen to reach
for example the a7 square
sorry b7 square without the black queen
interfering
so queen to a6 of course black will try
and stop this
with any means possible king to h4 now
by white
trying to improve the activity of the
king uh
sorry uh king the h4 uh and now queen to
a2 so black just keeps an eye on the
pawn and making it hard for white to
reach any
any of the squares here so here we have
h3 by white
and queen back to a5 black doesn't
really have much options he can just
repeat moves we have queen to d7
and now queen to b4 with check king to
h5
and now queen to a3 going after after
the pawn here while
keeping an eye on this pawn uh because
you you kind of don't want to allow
something like
capturous queen and then the queen
captures on h3
will be checkmate so uh we have king
back to g4
and now queen to e3 again uh what do you
play here
uh it kind of seems like you're allowing
this a8 queen
but if you do this it's just h5 check a
very nasty trick
captures and now queen to g5 with
checkmate
so instead after queen to e3 y doesn't
fall for this white plays
h4 prevents any queen g5 action in the
future
and now queen e4 check king to h5
queen f3 check and now g4 and here
uh you can see that the white king can
no longer move anywhere
so queen to e4 and you have to be very
careful you constantly have to keep an
eye on these two squares
uh if you allow any checks it's
checkmate and also the black queen
still covers the a8 square so how can
white advance here we have queen to f7
keeping an eye on these two squares and
also the pawn and black just plays
queen to c6 uh we have queen to e7
again just uh trying to see what happens
here and here
black gives white a chance queen to a4
is the move you want to play because it
attacks the pawn
and also well also keeps an eye on the
queening square
however black played queen to d5 here
and now we have a very interesting move
uh he allows white to play queen to e8
but here black actually thought he
tricked white uh because
uh you'll see why here uh queen the b7
was played
and uh well now it's white to play we've
reached the position from the thumbnail
feel free to pause the video and find
the winning move for white
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations
on under promoting the pawn and for
those who
just want to enjoy the show it's pawn
here but you don't bring a queen into
the game or the knight
or the rook you have to bring a bishop
into the game if you bring anything else
into the game
it it just doesn't work and i'm gonna
show you why it doesn't work because
this was black's idea this is why black
even allowed this because if you bring
the queen into the game
just queen f7 check and the king has
nowhere to go the queen has to be
captured and it's stalemate because the
queen covers this square
it's absolutely the same if you bring a
rook into the game because the rook will
also cover the h8 square just queen f7
check
captures and it's it's stalemate you
cannot move the king and also you cannot
push the pawn
so uh queen doesn't work rook doesn't
work
you might also try the knight saying
okay but at least i'm up a piece but
it's still not enough
uh you're still gonna well how how does
the knight leave the cage
how can the knight move away from here
you can try some ideas like g5 okay you
can bust open the position prevent any
uh ideas like that but it's still going
to be hard and if you try something like
queen to c8 again this is checkmate
so like i said only thing you can try
something like g5 and then after some
trades happen
captures captures and captures you can
then play something like queen g6 check
king g8 and now try something let's say
queen c6 try and get the knight in
but after something like king h7 knight
c7 and
queen somewhere let's say queen to f2
it's going to be extremely hard
for white king to to get out of all the
perpetual checks
so we we go back to this position where
queen to b7 was played
the only move that's winning for white
is pawn to a8
with a bishop and this is now this is
not terrifying for black because black
didn't consider this idea and now queen
to f7 check doesn't work
because after queen captures it's not
stalemate uh the
bishop does not cover the h8 square and
you have a move so it's gonna be
a very quick checkmate you go here you
have to
push a pawn unfortunately for for you
and then queen queen g7 will be
checkmate
so after this a8 uh bishop move
the game still continued uh black played
uh queen to b3 he now has to try
anything to to try and uh survive this
maybe if white plays a silly move then
he can still deliver checkmate on f7
uh but white did not play all of this
just a blunder now so here
queen to d7 keeping an eye on f7 queen
to g8 and now comes
bishop to d5 slowly but surely uh
getting closer to the black king
queen to f8 and now bishop to f7
preparing bishop g6
check so not much you can do here king
h8 and
now uh there is queen to e8 uh sorry a
queen to quinte8 by white
uh you also have this very interesting
king g6 idea
i'm going to show it because it's super
fun there's no move you can play you
have to try something like h fun
h5 but then queen to d1 and then after
captures captures there's no defense
against queen to h4 and it's just game
over
but a lot of things are winning for
white so why doesn't really care queen
e8
and now you have to trade with captures
captures
uh and king to h7 bishop back to f7
forcing black to move king h8 king g6
now
uh and here h5 uh of course you don't
want to play captures
that's just stalemate again you haven't
got this
you haven't gotten this far to blunder
now so here king captures allowing this
pawn to move
so king h7 and now bishop back to e8
king g8 and now came to g6 and it was in
this position
that oleg kaminsky resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
after you make a move king of fade or
king h8 doesn't really matter
uh you're just going to kick away the
king and now you cannot keep on
defending the g7 pawn
captures and now the h pawn of course is
winning
so it's a it's a fine game fine opening
fine middle game uh fine uh ending but
this uh this position after queen to b7
allowing this uh
pawn let's see it once again in slow
motion let's do it like this
all right bishop comes into the game i
mean simply amazing
so this is a one another rare case of uh
not just an under promotion sometimes
you can do an under promotion to avoid
let's say something
by bringing anything but a queen into
the game but here
it has to be a bishop and that's why
it's it's beautiful
and that's why chess will always be
beautiful
so uh that's uh that's the game i do
hope you guys enjoyed and that your
friends at the bar in the library will
also
enjoy it immensely i would like to thank
yogis eden
uh mark hichman uh axel manoj theo shepa
and william f field for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your one of the suggestions and
whatever else happens
in the chess world a really big
tournament uh starts today so we're
going to cover that as well
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday